a ghost story was directed by David
Lowery and star Casey Affleck and Rooney
Mara and is the very upbeat and
unconventional tale of a husband who
dies and wakes up in the hospital
looking like a child's Halloween costume
version of a ghost and we follow him on
an existential journey through his past
his future and we watch him try to find
something he's searching for on paper
the thing sounds really cheesy and it
could have turned out really bad
gratefully David Lowry script in his
direction is pretty airtight this film
is so emotionally impactful i sat during
the credits for about four minutes and
complete silence without saying anything
the ending of the film and the journey
that led to the end hit me so much in my
gut that I was pretty much leveled by
this movie emotionally it's one of the
saddest movies I have ever seen in my
life it explores death time what exactly
the meaning of life is is there a
meaning to life what someone goes
through after death the pain that
someone deals with when it comes to loss
all of these things are explored almost
entirely through imagery there is very
sparse dialogue in this film there's a
lot of visual storytelling and David
Lowry really succeeds with that there's
even a few uses of subtitles that
surprised me quite a bit as I describe
this movie to you it sounds more and
more absurd with everything I say but
that certainly had something to do with
the fact that I liked it so much it was
very different and highly original it
also plays with horror movie tropes
lights coming on books being knocked out
of bookshelves weird sound in the night
why do those sounds and those things
happen is it because some demonic
presence is in our house trying to mess
with us or could there be a more deeper
meaning behind that could it be more
than just bump in the night thrills this
movie is gorgeous the visuals are
incredible the cinematography was
absolutely mesmerizing it's shot in four
by three with rounded edges something
like I'm doing right now just because I
like this movie so much and I wanted to
tribute it and the visual look certainly
had something to do with the way to film
impacted me because it felt very old
school there was something about it that
felt almost like I was watching
someone's home movie which may have been
his goal I don't know but it felt like I
was watching just something sound like
it wasn't supposed to be playing on the
theater screen there was something
really audacious about it that left off
the screen and just it just hit me man
it really really really got me this
movie just left me really happy actually
it's a very sad film but I've said this
before I can watch like a really really
fucked-up disturbing movie with a lot of
violence and horrific sad things and
dramatic power and not be depressed
because it's so good like if I see a
film that's made this well even if it
makes you feel like you're just a cretin
which this movie kind of does it makes
you feel like you're nothing I just left
the theater so energized because I had
witnessed a filmmaker who had a message
who had a vision and was able to share
it so well and it didn't seem
pretentious either that was something I
was concerned about there are movies
like this that try to have messages that
try to say things and quite often I'll
leave the theater thinking well that was
just nothing a bunch of pretty scenes
with really nothing going on and I'm
sure a lot of people are going to feel
that way about a ghost story
anyone who goes to this movie thinking
it's paranormal activity part 22 is
going to be really disappointed this is
not a ghost movie in your stereotypical
Hollywood sense it's an emotional
journey and it's one that left a bruise
in the best way I adored this film and I
have only one issue with it there's a
scene that stuck out like a sore thumb
that has a lot of great dialogue but it
felt like it was the film telling me
what it was about and I was already
keyed into the director and what he was
trying to do I didn't really need to
have a character explain it to me it
felt too much like talking down to the
audience and I just felt out of left
field besides that one scene the way
this film builds from beginning to end
is remarkable it's as I said a beautiful
film and I don't think you should miss
it I'm going to give a ghost story and a
guys thank you very much as always for
watching look forward to the start of my
Stephen King series this Sunday with a
hilarious 'ti I want to start my Stephen
King series off with a hilarious 'ti and
I'm excited to do it oh my gosh this
movie I'm going to talk about honestly
changed my life it honestly it was like
the room troll to level change in my
life I am so excited to talk about it
guys thank you very much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck my eyes
[Music]